[Music]
while I was in art school I studied
graphic design came out as a graphic
designer after a few years working for
somebody I started working for myself
using my design skills and treating
everything like a design practice I was
able to become a designer business
leader type which was the inspiration
for us
Adie EO is a combination of a strategic
business executive matched with a
problem-solving designer when you look
at design lead companies or companies
that are embracing design they are
thriving from a financial perspective
and also thriving from a employee
happiness perspective I think de Oh
leaders are pretty easy to spot CEOs are
inherently change agents they are
looking to impact the status quo the
second one is risk-taking understanding
the need and the way to take smart risks
along the way so that change could
happen the third one is having a gut
intuition and mapping that with metrics
as part of the decision-making process
for DEA's the fourth one is systems
thinking being able to look at a system
instead of thinking linearly
the fifth one is being people-centred
and the sixth one ultimately is getting
stuff done
my advice to you
is to embrace the diversity
voices that more and more companies
[Music]
makes that company
[Music]
be adaptable and embrace the change I'm
Maria Judas and I'm a design leader and
co-author of the book rise the de
[Music]
you